got a question
for both of you to start what is
something unique about the way
clear runs a set that you wish you saw
on more sets out there
she's the zen master mistress
she's she on the days that we had the
most crazy stuff to do
she was the most calm the most zen-like
the most
smiling person on the set it was crazy
i've never seen any director certainly
not any male director
who had this quality it was fascinating
i completely agree she was so
even keeled throughout the whole thing
so funny always
making jokes with us and you just i
think we all felt so
safe in her hands because also she
co-wrote it so we knew
you know she knows every facet of the
story and all the characters and
it was very impressive the way she was
able to let all of us
inhabit the characters in our own way
and play off of each other and really be
in the moment without pinning us in and
at the same time
she was the captain of the ship she was
guiding it with such a steady
gentle hand i love hearing that i also
have a little bit of an obsession
with asking about a director's tell
behind the monitor
so what does she do that signals to you
that she is absolutely loving a take
that she's getting
gosh i'm like how often was i behind the
monitor with
i feel like we all were in all the
scenes yeah
we were in these big scenes with so many
people that i don't think we got to
watch her face watching us um
so i'm not sure we would know but
she she's just she took
delight in all of us all of the time
which of course makes you want to
walk through fire for her because she's
so lovely
totally she that's what i was gonna say
i was like we didn't need to be behind
the monitor because she was not
withholding at all like you knew when
she loved to take because she'd run in
and be like
that was hilarious you know so
i also wanted to ask you guys a little
bit about reaction shots because i feel
like we don't talk about them
nearly enough and in this movie in
particular it says so much about the
family dynamic without you guys actually
saying any dialogue so
in this movie in particular did you see
a
like a noticeable up in attention to
detail in that respect
we were fascinated by each other's
performances
and and there was such a feeling of
family so there was
such an intense connection with the
people in the scene with you
and um it was it so
i i i think some of that was just
um didn't you find that we had such
easy and deep easy connection with each
other from
day one absolutely and i think that the
characters are so well drawn they're
written well
they're incredibly specific and unique
to themselves and then
working with such skilled actors i felt
like every actor came in and was so
present and really brought something
grounded and connected to each of their
characters
so we there really was that present
energy in every scene it wasn't like
now let's pick up some reaction shots
from alice and go
like i feel like that never happened we
all wanted to be on set all the time so
it's not like you were ever faking
something acting with a piece of tape
and
you know there are the scenes mackenzie
has her big emotional scene and there
was not a dry eye
in the house every take all of us
whether we were on camera or not
were crying so it's very genuine what
you're seeing
i feel like you could feel that while
you're watching the movie
congratulations
on this i absolutely love it thank you
guys for your time today
thank you